I think economic still has a lot to
offer I think economics is practiced by
most of the profession in the public eye
is full of hubris and should be much
were a full humility
I am Nicolas be with reason TV and we're
very happy to be talking with Russ
Roberts he's a research fellow at the
Hoover Institution at Stanford
University Russ thanks for joining us my
pleasure Nick we wanted to talk with you
about econ talk when did it start
and what what are you trying to do with
econ talk so it comes out every week
pretty reliably rain or shine holiday or
don't holiday 6:30 a.m. Eastern Time so
a lot of people move to California's
they get a little earlier 3:30 or Hawaii
or you know Japan yeah but it is out at
6:30 every Monday is pretty much
reliably you have over the years you
have I mean interviewed just the vast
you know a vast assortment of people
both a lot of you know big names in the
free-market movement but then also range
of wider people like dan pink and author
who is a former Al Gore speechwriter
Stiglitz yep okay Stiglitz not not a not
a big fan favorite these days among free
marketing people robert frank oslo joe
nocera the new york times columnist
since at least since the financial
crisis you've stressed and a lot of your
speaking engagements a lot of your
writing the the lack of knowledge within
the kind of economics field of like you
know really understanding why things
happen the way they do when if your
starting point which is very Hayekian
you're focusing on the limits of our
knowledge do you just kind of fall down
a rabbit hole of really not being able
to make any kind of meaningful declan
declarative sentence it is true that
over the last few years i've become much
more Hayekian in in terms of what i
think we know and don't know his nobel
prize address which i always recommend
is the pretense of knowledge which is
really an attack on macroeconomics
pretense of understanding we can steer
the economy we understand how it works
in some level of detail and his view was
we can't not just that we haven't yet we
can't it's not feasible and as a result
what we're left with is some general
principles I think those general
principles are pretty timeless so I
haven't rejected those I think economic
still has a lot to offer I think
economics is practiced by most of the
profession in the public eye is full of
hubris and should
much were full of humility well talk a
little bit about that you I mean you
mentioned that you've interviewed Justus
Stiglitz a big proponent of stimulus
spending and we you know we could have
done so much more we should have done so
much more where does he get it wrong or
how do you know that he's wrong
if you're kind of starting from the fact
that we really don't know all that much
well it could be right he could
certainly provide some evidence that
he's right some fancy statistical
analysis and the people who think he's
wrong can provide some fancy statistical
analysis says they can't convince each
other of either viewpoint it suggests to
me that that statistical analysis is not
so scientific right probably falls into
the realm of what higher called
scientism fake science oppose science I
think it's very hard to argue in logical
terms that spending money unwisely is
the way to get wealthy it's hard to
understand that why you would argue
that's what stimulus money that was and
I would certainly say that if I'm gonna
justify spending eight hundred and
twenty billion dollars of other people's
money
pretty good case that it that it's that
it's a good idea I wouldn't take it as a
priori true which is what unfortunately
though I think a lot of macro economists
do and if not I mean that's fiscal
stimulus under they the government is
kind of borrowing money to spend it but
then there's also monetarist stimulus
which is Healy said the Fed should be
yeah you know we haven't had enough qyz
yeah do you think that that suffers from
the same kind of presumption of truth
and that the only way we know we didn't
spend enough as if the economy didn't go
the way we wanted it so yeah and I think
the mainstream view is boy if the Fed
hadn't saved Bear Stearns creditors if
it hadn't injected the seven hundred
billion dollars a tarp we hadn't had all
these unprecedented interventions paying
interest on reserves these were all
crucial to save the economy we're on the
edge of a cliff and you say how do you
know when you want to have some evidence
for that for doing these unprecedented
violations of the rule of law for having
the Fed really an unaccountable
institution start doing these kind of
breaking of contracts and
and they don't have any evidence for
that it's sort of presumable of course
they save the world we don't know so I'm
very wary of those kind of interventions
because I see the other costs which is
the degradation of contracts the ability
to plan and lay bottom the light over
the wire cluster okay yeah
the default hypothesis it didn't work
I'm willing to accept the possibility
that it would have been worse but if
you're gonna make that claim you got to
give me some evidence other than just
saying so you have left George Mason
University where you're a longtime
professor of economics and you moved on
to the Hoover Institution talk a little
bit about what kind of motivated that
change and also what the project at
Hoover that you're going to be doing is
so I'm still keeping an affiliation
George Mason but I'm moving to hit the
Hoover Institution at Stanford full time
and I won't be teaching in the classroom
as I have for quite a while which is a
big change for me and that'll free up
some time to do some new stuff they
don't allow the old stuff so we do an
econ talk half a hike hope to write some
books but I've started a and some rap
videos as well yeah sure I hope so what
what are you doing with Hoover the woods
so the new project is called the numbers
game I'm gonna be interviewing
economists talking about charts and data
so what you'll hear is the audio of that
conversation what you'll see are the
charts and the data animated and
annotated in ways to help you understand
it better when will that be coming
online first ones out is a pilot you can
find it at YouTube by googling Russ
Roberts numbers game second one should
be out soon if not I don't know when
this layer but it'll be out soon and
there'll be more yeah all right well
Russ Roberts economist plain talker and
bringer of light and wisdom thank you so
much your kind neck appreciate it for
reason TV I'm Nicholas P
you